dr heavenly season eight of married to
medicine
is here how are you feeling are you
excited are you bracing for
impact is it a mix of emotions
i think it's always a mix of emotions
but i'm always excited i think you're
going to see a different side of all of
us
good and bad but uh i think you're going
to enjoy it
we ended last season at the reunion you
and simone
seemed seconds away from ripping each
other's faces off and then you were on
the floor rolling around with quad
riding you i thought
yes we're on a fresh start here we go
seems like things didn't move forward
from there
why didn't they i don't want to be messy
but you know what i can only speak the
truth and that's all i can think of
simone's husband and i had interaction
on twitter after telling him multiple
times to stop i responded one time
once and she can't get over that i think
the issue is
dr jackie kind of agreed with me because
there were certain things he said that
she didn't like
so she said hey i'm going to stay out of
it and
simone just stopped speaking about us
rather than going to a husband having
him accountable for what
he did to go back to that reunion moment
for you that felt like a genuine moment
and it's simone was the roadblock she's
the one who chose not to move forward
after that
right right because we all were open i
called her several times i don't know if
they
don't you know i got this every time she
wasn't responsive i invited her out she
wasn't responsible
and i did nobody sir you know i don't do
nothing to nobody all i do is respond
when people keep
attacking me like you said over and over
again i just think that simone needs to
own her [ __ ] and just move forward
really ain't nobody holding no grudges
we all get into it everybody has done
wrong
in this group you know if we have
grudges here we would never get anywhere
right i mean that's kind of the name of
the game isn't it it's when you look at
the big picture
you're on reality tv this is kind of
what what you signed up for
and the interesting thing to me is
i don't do anything differently from
anybody else but they
they their responses to it is different
maybe i come too hard
i don't know i just respond to whatever
they give me and i think i'm coming at
the same level
how do you feel about simone blaming you
for her issues with jackie i think
simone's looking for an excuse i think
it's her husband he needs to own it
that's what it is i didn't do anything
wrong i think that i came he gave his
opinion to me and my husband and that
really took me out you could give your
opinion to me all the time
when you bring my man name in it i'ma
respond
because you allowed me to give my
opinion of you and i did
so to mommy the owner she knows this i
don't know she'll ever own up to it but
she knows what it is
jackie has nothing to do with it and she
knows it she's mad at
jackie for not defending her against a
friend that we were all friends i mean
you could say
20 years but you can't say a better
friend than i've been to her
and i miss you and i'm not going to say
it no oh i'm tired of saying anything
say it anymore i'm tired of saying
that i'm not kissing nobody else
you don't need to say i feel like i knew
more
last year we sat down me
you fell in the jacket she's really
throwing herself in the mix of this
whole simone jackie thing how do you
feel about her trying to play
i don't know puppet master fixer i think
that toya
um i'm going to say this the nicest way
i can't need something to do
something else to do i mean her kid's in
school so we can't say she to stay at
home mom
she needs something to do something to
make a life feel more fulfilled
that's my thought on toy really because
she's really critical about people that
are doing way more than she is
so she needs to do something so she even
has an inkling
of what it takes to run a business run a
family run a life
run household do you first and then come
out
so toya needs something to do that's why
what
family's just rude when i went through
the trailer though it seems
like there might be some positive
movement with you and simone what can we
expect what journey are we going on this
year and i could have to be honest i
don't know if tony one told we still not
speaking we had
positive movement during the filming but
to this day we really
not and not where we were okay so we're
in for some sort of roller coaster
absolutely we had a little bit of a cash
shake-up
this season how do you feel about mariah
exiting the group
once again i just feel like whose friend
was mariah who was her friend on the
show so
who could she film with i think this
show is based on a group of friends you
know
and nobody really mariah they don't i
mean and
i just think that her you know i don't
know but um the cash shake up i think it
was a good
good move i think that we have um a
great addition to the cast anila sancha
and i've gotten to know her and um i can
honestly say she's the friend
okay that makes me feel good because
when you look at the trailer she makes
some digs at you
anybody can be a dentist
but when i respond they mad forever i
take the dicks hey i'm a deafness you
know what i do well as dentistry i'm
happy with my
position as a dentist it does not bother
me when you take a dig at them they hurt
forever
and i don't do anything more deep in my
opinion now you know
you know but then they do i was going to
ask you how do you feel about
the constant attacks on oh dentists
you're not a real doctor blah blah blah
but it's
you're laughing all the way to the bank
i make more money in my hours or not
that i would not get up
at my bed to deliver somebody else's
baby i just couldn't do it you know what
i'm saying
if they chose to do what they did i'm
all for it and i think they're needed
but don't fail me for what i'm doing i
do great at it and i love it
and i'm a blogger too and that ain't a
real job to me
you work yeah i'm a vlogger i didn't
think that was a job
some ghosts of m2m past floating in this
season
lisa nicole is back in the mix how are
you feeling about her showing up
this nicole is hungry and she's thirsty
i mean she came at me attacking me from
the very beginning and i ain't seen this
within years
honestly i didn't know what her problem
was with me but
you know what a part of me feels sorry
for lisa nicole because every time she
comes back she gets the bad end of the
stick you know what i'm saying
yeah i mean she coaches me and i stay
ready
i know you want to be like me [ __ ] that
can't keep a man
[Music]
no no no and then we've got carrie wells
and og
floating on by how do you feel about her
popping up you know what
carrie takes digs at me as well but
i like kerry for some reason i like her
but what really touched my heart with
carrie was during the black lives
matter's movement
she went over and beyond and i don't
care what nobody says
a white woman is needed in our movement
it helps our moon we need
everybody and what i saw was everybody
of all nationality
all races everybody from all genders
was there saying hey you know what black
lives do matter and this is something
that's wrong and carrie was at the front
line so i would always
respect her for that i love hearing that
we pick up on your
story right when the movement was
surging last summer
so what does it mean to bring this to tv
right now it brings back so many
memories but it will always
be relevant because this has been going
on for
so many years you know i don't know if
y'all saw where damon talked about some
of his experiences being a black man
and you know it's so impactful like i
said i think this season
is different from the past but i think
it's better
honestly what do you hope the viewers
take away from
hearing these stories you know being a
black female having a black brother and
black men in my life all around
i honestly thought that everybody knew
the struggles that we went through i
really really did but coming in meeting
anila and some other people that are not
of color
they just didn't know i don't know if
they were just not exposed to it or
whatever
in my mind i would have thought
everybody you know so i think what we're
getting out of it is
exposure anytime there's something going
wrong in this country or any other
country all you can do is put it out
there
for the world to see and then the people
that's doing it have to
respond to it and i think one of the
things about this country that takes
pride in
their their brand the way they look to
other people
and they're out there being policemen of
the world
taking care of apartheid and other
things in other countries and they ain't
even solved their own
here so now we need to take a look at
ourselves before we can move forward
in another country or being involved in
anything else a hundred percent i think
you put that perfectly
i also thought it was so meaningful
it's a brief moment in the premiere but
you do get to speak about
how much more devastating covid was to
the black community which i don't think
people paid enough attention to
what do you hope people take away from
seeing how you guys dealt with the
pandemic especially as medical
professionals
one of the great things that takes us
away from other reality tv shows is that
we're all
professional you know my husband's a
physician emergency medicine so you see
us at the front lines
we get to show you what we actually went
through and i don't think a lot of
people
see the intricate involvement of how it
affects doctors lives and their you know
and their in their livelihood so it's
amazing to see how the different
dynamics of american medicine which
were shown on a very very light note i
have to tell you about a moment that
brought me so much joy
last year when big mike interrupted your
live stream
oh you were watching big night
uh-oh oh lord you scared me big bank i
ain't gonna do
what the hell oh my god they say my
response was i
did not know what that was honestly
initially
and uh we're just gonna pray for him and
you know what and since then i've never
let anybody in my life after that i mean
i learned my lesson you know i thought
it was fun the interaction you know
nah you can't do that well it's fun
until somebody turns it into a porn show
absolutely jesus did y'all see that
oh my gosh oh that oh y'all gonna send
me off of here
trying to get my pay shut down i had to
figure out how to edit that out
you know so i learned something from it
so okay you took a moment away
yeah your reaction is it it's less about
what big mike was doing and more about
how you responded to it that brought me
joy
hopefully y'all didn't see that on my
page what the hell that was i hope you
all didn't see that praise god
i think i watched that clip probably 100
200 times because it makes me laugh
every time
so people got something out of it even
though you almost had a heart attack
right i was like oh my god what is that
jesus it was it was it was amazing it
was something great it was crazy
to wrap things up anything else you want
the fans to know about season eight
maybe one word to describe what we're
gonna see i think
that i can't think of a better word than
simply amazing amazing you got to see
all of us
all of us in action dr damon i think you
got to see what he does
cove and testing how he jumped out in
the front and he did something
i just sat down and wait waited for
things to happen
um i just think it's an amazing season